hey everyone happy Friday this is Mike
from order flows and I'm pleased to
present to this presentation with
investor inspiration this is my order
flows 2.0 what you need to know about
order flow and my goal for you today is
to teach you the most important part of
order flow I'm going to explain new
developments in order flow analysis I'm
going to show you why you don't need to
predict the market to be a successful
trader and hopefully by the end I'm
going to convince you to stop waiting
for confirmation and start trading you
know that's what trading is about it's
about actually trading you know everyone
likes to sit around wait for
confirmation but in the meantime the
market is trading back and forth and
they're missing their trades and this
morning this is Friday August 3rd
there's a great set up in the order flow
about 3:30 in the morning if you're
awake at that time was a great buying
opportunity right off the low you could
have been getting long around the 28 26
and 1/2 27 area and you know hopefully
taken all the way up to the 26 28 34
area so a good six and a half or seven
points in the e-mini 's and I'm gonna
show you in this presentation how you
can find trades like that and what I'm
presenting here is what I've developed
for myself and built my trading career
on you know I've spent my time my
professional career as a trader
you know as an institutional trader
that's what I did that's what paid my
bills you know it's not something where
I sat down and you know I couldn't trade
so I started programming no you know I
was a trader that's what I did so I hope
you can find things you can use or
things you can modify in adapt for your
own trading and it's important to know
that you don't have to follow what I say
just because I say it you know you have
to evaluate everything you come across
whether it's from me or one of the other
speakers here today and decide if it's
going to help you you know if not reject
it you know trading is a is a journey
the emotional sometimes and more
importantly it's a mental journey you
got to find what works for you and apply
it you know not everything is going to
work for everybody else now if you stick
around to the end I got a special gift
for you it's it's my book trading order
flow it's 150 pages and you're gonna get
the pdf version you're not gonna get an
actual hard bound copy sent to you but
I'll show you at the end how to get it
now for those of you that are new to one
of my presentations let me just explain
Who I am my name is Michael bottles I'm
the founder and owner
trader of order flows calm since 2015
it's 2018 now it's three years prior to
that I spent eight years at JP Morgan as
vice president in the futures trading as
a trader
okay I wasn't like sitting in an office
looking at spreadsheets and coming out
and tapping the guy on the shoulder oh
you're taking too much risk or you know
you're losing too much money no I sat on
the trading desk in at five in the
morning out at five at night
I did that for eight years and you know
it's a very tiring job let me tell you
it's not all it's not like you watch the
show billions and you know you think
it's some glamorous thing it there are
times it sucked but that's that's life
that's that's what it's like honestly I
spent four years at Cargill as a trading
desk manager even said I went to
Singapore to supper training that's when
the exchange futures exchange closed
there I spent three years at Commerce
Bank because a license your ex trader I
traded ones bobble Schatz tax euro
stocks and against all the US products
it's been two years a TDF man the big
English global trading company as a
global macro trader and I started on the
seamy floor with Dean Witter spent three
years on the Globex desk there it was
called the Globex desk because that's
when Globex was just starting up and you
know all the the members member firms
you know we're pushed by the exchange to
have a Globex desk and you know it was
the terminal from seeing me which was
Globex project a from the Board of Trade
and nymex access in addition and we were
trading all the futures markets around
the world as well so it was a great
opportunity you know when I was on the
floor I thought you know I was in the
Deutsche marks and Swiss francs I
thought that was the world you know
maybe you know if it was funny because
you know when you're down there on the
trading floor no fortune there's no more
training for us but yeah you're just
involved in one market maybe two or
three and it you know if you follow you
know if you're if you if you're trading
you know Deutsche marks and Swiss francs
and then you can talk about say Japanese
yen people be like wow you know you're a
genius
but you know and when he left when I
left the floor it's like a whole
different world evolved you know as
I was introduced to all the contracts
around the world you know hang saying
you know nikai footsie dax you know all
the stock indices around the world even
the commodity contracts you know gas oil
you know things heat in the United
States you don't even think about
rapeseed and canola oil you don't really
think about that stuff in the US you
just think of what's traded here in the
US and go from there but you know I
really have experienced trading it in
all the different futures markets around
the world in different conditions and
that's important information that you
can't get just by trading one market at
a time but in 2013
I left JP Morgan to spend more time with
my family and trading on my own you know
honestly like I said you know coming in
at 5:00 in the morning leaving 5:00 at
night plus the commute time spending
more time with the jokerz in my office
than with my my family and I decided no
that's not what I want to do you know I
don't wanna be 50 and have a heart
attack you know because I'm spending
more time trading in the office and time
with your family you know if you have
kids you understand how important it is
to spend time with them and you know
that was the decision that I made
so I started trading for myself and I
said you know I want to write a book you
know writing a book is there's a lot
more work than I thought honestly you
know a bit of I'm like well the on the
type works I decide I want to do
something I'll do it but it's you know I
started out writing the book and it's
like after three months it's like well
you know this is actually a lot more
work and you know so I was doing that
doing that and I was trading at the same
time but I was using another vendors
volume foot print shard in my training
that I've I've used for a while and I
was getting frustrated in the sense that
you know I could only really concentrate
on one market at a time and you know
when I was even trading in the bank you
know I would basically concentrate on a
few markets but you know my size was
there so it was big size and we're doing
a lot of volume so whether it wasn't an
issue but when you're out there training
for yourself you know you want to try
and watch a few markets at once you know
three or four if you can because it's
going to give you more training
opportunities and I found myself missing
trade sometimes because I'd be in a
position in say the
mini ESPYs and there's something
happening in the euro currency that I
didn't pick up on because I was too
focused on one market but if I could
have a way that the software would
highlight to me things that I like to
look for in the order flow it can free
me up to visually see what's happening
in other markets as they're happening so
even if I was in a position and
something that was happening in another
market I can see it you know I could
free up my brain so to speak to see it
so in 2015 I created the order flows
trader software on order fellas calm and
to take the order flow analysis to the
next level so I programmed these tools
that I use I call them tools
it's basically my ways of looking at the
order flow chart to see price rejection
price support absorption and these other
little market nuances and it runs on
ninjatrader seven or eight because
that's where my my programmer that's
that was a specialty so you know I went
with there and it's pretty simple
program to use if you're new to it it
doesn't take that long to get the hang
of but you know my whole goal was to
take the heavy lifting of analysis off
my shoulders to put it onto the software
so that I could watch what's happening
in multiple markets at the same time
because you know what happens sometimes
is in the markets there's nothing going
on and you tend to get distracted you
know maybe you'll start looking at
Facebook or something or surfing the
internet but if I could you know just
glance up at a chart really quick and
you know because there's a certain color
on the screen for telling me of support
or resistance or but you know something
some sign on the screen then you know
it'll catch my attention and then I
could go focus on that when it's
happening and that was the whole goal so
let me be clear you know you have to
make trading decisions you know that's
what training is about the other day
it's you deciding hey I'm going to take
this trade or not and order flow allows
you to view the market in ways you
haven't before the best way for me to
describe it is like being a doctor okay
when you're sick you go see the doctor
what does he do he takes your
temperature he looks at your eyes he
looks in your ears looks in your mouth
you know sometimes I
could go for an x-ray and it's from that
he's able to diagnose what's wrong with
you you know from their x-ray he can see
inside what's going on that's why he's
looking inside your body and everything
you're checking your blood flow and
that's what order flow is like all right
it's it's seeing inside what's happening
in the market seeing what's going on
with you know the flow of the blood or
the flow of trading and again it really
opens up the market to a whole new view
that you probably hadn't before know you
know you know you've always heard the
statistic you know ninety percent of
traders lose money you know I'd say 90
to 95 percent of traders lose their
account in the first year but you know
they probably just they blow it up you
know it goes to zero or you know they
take a drawdown of 80% and then just
pull the money out why do you think that
is it's because what they're doing is
they don't know how to trade you know
they think they buy a book or two on
trading and they think there's a master
they read some guy on a forum you know
big lips ninety seven says oh you have
to trade it like this and that's the
only way to trade and you know they
don't understand how to trade they're
getting bad information from people they
don't know basically it says oh this is
I have to trade because I say so
well I'm not even saying that I'm saying
you know if this resonates with you then
great you know I'm trying to give you an
edge you know I've had an edge in
trading because I've been successful
trading you know you're not gonna last
eight years at a bank like JP Morgan
trading unless you are good at it period
you know if you're losing money quarter
after quarter cost them the money they
don't pay you to sit in the seat and
piss away their money no you know they
want results so stop doing what the
losing traders are doing you know do
something different and you know that
that's like like Apple right for many
years Apple made you know Apple came out
with the first home computer basically
and they made a lot of money but then
what happens is they never really went
further and you know they had you know a
great guy in Steven jobs you know who
had the idea to make the iPhone you know
there are already phones on the market
okay but you know he said you know I you
know I want a phone I can do stuff
differently and and look at them now
just yesterday the heat they hit a
trillion dollars in market cap wise
because they took something that was
just a basic tool and they made it
better you know they found an edge in
the market you know they improved
something and that's what trading is
about is about having an edge in the
market now before I jump into everything
a brief disclaimer this presentation is
for educational and informational
purposes only and should not be
considered a solicitation at buy or sell
a futures contract or make any other
type of investment decision futures
trading contains substantial risk and is
not for every investor investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
trading only those with sufficient risk
capital should consider trading past
performances it's not necessarily
indicative of future results now the
reason why I go through this disclaimer
every video and every webinar I do is
because you know I want you to
understand there is risk involved in
trading nothing is 100% and you know I
laugh at these claims
you know 99% winning trades or even I
see 100 percent winning trades ya know
it doesn't work that way you know I'm a
big believer in seasonal patterns I have
to admit that's that's a something I've
always been interested in ever since you
know I know cuz you know I worked at
Cargill and I know there are seasonal
tendencies in a lot of commodities and
often times you know I see people say
well you know this market has a seasonal
tendency of 95% well when you take the
trade you just happen to be that 5% of
time it doesn't work out you know there
is nothing is 100% in the market so just
keep that in mind so in order flow there
are three building blocks that you need
to know to understand order flow to put
it all together to go from a jar full of
Legos to building a nice Lego house and
it's Delta which is basically the
measure of aggressiveness in a bar you
know if you have positive Delta you have
net aggressive buyers if you have
negative Delta you have net aggressive
selling and what's aggressive buying an
aggressive selling aggressive vine is
when somebody lifts the offer buys the
offer aggressive selling is when someone
sells into the bid and think of it like
this you go to you want to buy a car and
you go to a car dealer okay you want buy
this Corvette it's $80,000 but you don't
want to pay $80,000
the car dealer is a passive seller at
80,000 you think well I can buy this car
for 70,000 ok so you're a passive buyer
at 70,000 he's a passive seller at
80,000 well there's no trade going to
happen you know he's not gonna give me
the the car keys for 70,000 so what
happens is you one of you has to be
aggressive either he's gonna go if he
was aggressive he would say fine I'll
sell it to you at 70,000 he's the
aggressive seller if you say no I want
this car so I could get hot women you're
gonna be aggressive and buy you know
I'll pay eighty thousand here's your's
cash take it now you know then you're
being aggressive okay and it's like that
with the market if you buy at the market
you're aggressive buyer if you sell at
the market you're an aggressive seller
now the next thing is point of control
point of control every bar has one and
it's the point in the bar with the most
volume period you take the volume traded
on the bid trade it on the offer and
that's your point of control and lastly
is marketing balances and the marketing
balance is is when you have a ratio of
more aggressive buyers than sellers for
buying imbalance or more aggressive
sellers than buyers for selling
imbalance and the ratio that people use
is generally four to one that's that's
the racial it's sort of like an industry
standard
now again you don't have to use four to
one I know some people that use
different numbers higher numbers but
that's basically what constitutes a
market imbalances when you got more
aggressive buyers and sellers by a
certain amount so yeah the first thing
I'll talk about is the new developments
in order flow analysis and you know this
is important because like I said you
know when I started trading on my own
and I had a different volume footprint
chart it was just the simple volume
footprint chart and it just gave me the
volume you know I traded our price which
was nice to have him as good is basic
but I look back on it now you know five
years later from 2013 it hasn't changed
it still looks the same
they've made no new developments and and
why is that is because you know I think
the people that devised it they're just
programmers or not traders you know
they're now you see so many bond
footprint charts on the market almost
everybody has one and it's it's kind of
pointless because it's just like
somebody says well I can't trade I could
program so I'll create a volume
footprint chart rather than having a
trader saying I like the volume
footprint chart but I wanted to do this
for me and then that's where the order
flows trainer comes in and it's
available for ninja trader seven and
eight and the original ninja trader
seven version of order flows trader is
had trap traders single prints order
flows divergence and ratios I won't get
into that here you can go to my website
and watch some of the other videos on it
but in the new release of the software
that we did earlier this year we added
prominent pointing controls market
sweeps multiple imbalances and we
enhanced the trap traders feature so you
can see more areas where traders are are
trapped in the market now let me just
explain what some of these mean is prime
opponent control it highlights the
opponent controls that are important
which often act as support or resistance
and knowing areas of support of
resistance it's important that way you
can take advantage of them when the
market reaches those prices again you
know you can see how the market often
reacts to areas problem opponent
controls wise because that's where you
have support that's where you have
resistance you see how the market comes
down here it's the support area rallies
up here hits a resistance area and comes
back down knowing where you have
supporter resistance is also important
it's because you know if you're going to
take a low risk trade you throw in a bid
somewhere around that prominent point of
control
with the stop just below it for when the
market comes back down to test that
support rather than have the market
trade trade trade and come back test it
then rally and say well I'm gonna get
long because we broke out through the
upside we got the double bottom in here
now you know that you could have a
potential for a double bottom because
you have support there and then the
market rallies up its gonna give you a
great trade opportunities in the market
it's a primary port of control
resistance level up here sells off or
does it sell off too before rolling back
up it rallies back up to a prominent
opponent control area right up in here
so it sells off rallies back up to your
problem opponent control where you have
resistance and then sells off again
market sweeps market sweeps our areas
where big traders sweep the market
either they buy or sell through several
price levels in one trade and you know
people
we'll say well you know people it's
stupid why would someone buy through
three price levels for price levels that
doesn't happen yeah I see people write
stuff like that on on these message
boards and it's you know it's people
have never traded really professionally
or institutionally rather and I need to
use the term professionally but traded
institutionally and move big-sized
understand on why it's done you know
institutional traders they only care
about average price they don't care
about I got 16 at this price 27 at this
price 37 at this price 62 at this price
just tell me what the average price is
and that's how they book the trade out
to ten decimal points actually nine
decimal points that's what they're
concerned in so they don't mind sweeping
through the market if they know or I
didn't imagine think about it if you're
a trader
you got 5000 means to buy you want to
get them out now you gonna sweep the
market if you want to get them on as
fast as possible now you know you people
workout goals and stuff but you know
when when hits the fan and stuffs
happening in the market and you know you
gotta buy boatload of anything you're
generally gonna buy it up try and buy it
up through three prices because if you
start finessing it your end up markets
gonna move and you're not gonna get
everything on and your average price is
going to be worse you know the old nymex
access trading system had a sweep
function on it you know this is back in
the 90s you know these old clunky
computers that was one of the functions
on access so that's why you see it
happening and I think in crude a bit
more than a lot of other markets is
because you know these cash traders will
be working something against cash and
they know that it's gonna cash markets
about the move so they'll sweep through
the market four or five price levels and
they do that regularly it happens still
today in every market you know here's
Nasdaq there's a one-minute chart you
see market sweep being indicated here in
the software and right before it sells
off you know this is a one minute chart
imagine you're getting you know you know
there's a sweeping activity here you get
short you know where's your stop going
to be it's just gonna be somewhere
behind where that sweep occurred and you
mentioned getting short here 7170 down
here right over the next five minutes it
trades all the way down to you know
below seventy one sixty which is right
here you know you got a prominent point
of control down here at 71 52 so say you
cover down here you know
71-57 7158 that's 12 12 handles in the
Nasdaq over five minutes you know here's
crude oil I come down and started
putting the pieces together prominent
point of control at the swing low start
railing up you got a red candle okay are
we coming back down nope big trader
comes in sweeps the market back up right
before the market continues its move on
higher so you know this is this is
important information and you know
that's why I said you know it'd be nice
if the software can do that for you and
it does now because you know that's what
we've programmed into the software to
help you with now another feature
another new development in order flow is
the multiple imbalance feature now what
it is it's it's three or more order flow
imbalances in the bar
it's similar to a stacking balance you
know if you're familiar with order flow
analysis in general you don't understand
what a stacking balances but what a
multiple imbalances is it's a a bar with
three or more imbalances in it they're
just not neatly stacked on top of each
other and it's important information why
is because you know that they're
aggressive sellers coming in and it's
just not it just unfortunate it's just
not stacked on top of each other now
there's a great example is the crude oil
so you hit a low prominent point of
control okay I think this is a low maybe
I'm not convinced yet next bar in
balancing balancing balance and balance
it's a nine price level bar it's an
eight range bar so there's nine price
levels in there and four of them are
imbalances okay if you're waiting for a
stacking balance it doesn't come till
twenty cents later meanwhile you miss
this area to be buying in down here at
7255 instead you're buying up here at
seventy to seventy-five you just gave up
an extra twenty cents in potential
profit you know another crude oil we
just come in here we're just sort of
hanging around going sideways putting in
a bottom then boom aggressive buyers
appear you know this is like the sign
from cod but you know a sign saying hey
you know what we're at this low like big
buyers it could be one it could be
multiple people coming in here thinking
this is a low price and they're being
aggressive they're tripping over each
other in their aggressiveness buying it
sort of skipping different price levels
you got one two three four
well imbalances in this bar and then the
market starts scooting higher higher
higher and again if you're just looking
for stacked imbalances you're not gonna
see it in here because there is no
stacked imbalances they're mixed in here
and the multiple imbalances will have a
magenta box around the bar you
unfortunately doesn't color it one color
for buy or one color for sell just more
as a visual tool it's a tool for you to
look at and analyze further you know
here you have a high double top
the first time you hit the top you got a
problem opponent control so you know
there's resistance second time you hit
it
you've got the divergence and you got
multiple imbalances so what's happening
you're up here at the high
you got a divergence and you see you've
got aggressive sellers coming in you
know that's important information you
know if you're at a high and aggressive
sellers are coming in people are coming
in now we're at this high sell let's
sell it that's important information you
should act on it and you know a couple
bars later you got a sweep coming in
here and the market sells off but you
know what this was the bar up here
everything yet primary point of control
you got divergence you got stacked in
balance multiple imbalances rather and
then you got a sweep if you know
everything in the order flow is telling
you hey you want to get short don't get
long here we're not going higher so the
second thing I'll talk about is the most
of what I consider the most important
part of order flow once you understand
this you know it really makes a big
difference in your trading and it's not
some big secret like oh the magician
pulls back the curtain not everything no
it's volume period that's the most
important part of order flow why is
because traded volume equals commitment
when someone gets into a trade they're
committed to the market because at some
point they're going to get out now yeah
not everything is not Irie position has
been put on to get out nowadays you got
all these index arms and you got all
these delta1 desks and stuff something's
go to delivery some things are cash
settled for purposes but generally the
95 percent of everything
someone gets into they're going to get
out at some point and well it's the
difference between
orders in the order book book the dome
versus orders traded well unfilled
orders indicated traders in tension
filled orders indicate a traders
commitment and that's important because
you know this is the dome right you can
see the markets oh nine and a half at
nine and three-quarters okay but up here
twenty eight ten and a half people oh my
gosh there's 1800 on the offer there you
know Warren Buffett's got an order up
there you know so you know forget up
there you got to sell it well as the
market you know if the markets nine and
a half at ninety three quarters yeah I'd
love to also sell it at ten and a half
I'd be willing to put something in there
maybe the market spikes up there and
comes off you know I'm happy days and
comes back down at nine and a half and
I'm short at ten and a half that's
that's great but as the market starts
ticking up if you've ever watched a dome
long enough you'll notice that as you
start getting up here start trading ten
and a quarter instead of 1878 now you're
only looking at six hundred and fifty
you know people they pull their offers
you know they back off you know they go
up to the eleven and a half or something
they or they just pull it for whatever
reason doesn't matter you know that's
just their intention you know when the
markets here at nine and a half yeah
everyone would like to sell ten and a
half
you know maybe they want the market to
go a little bit lower something you
necessarily throwing big offers a lot of
still some shenanigans being played in
the markets but you know when volume is
traded when orders are traded you know
it indicates a traders commitment and
you can see here right this is the
volume footprint chart you could see
down here at this low you got a
prominent party control you could see
you know three thousand contracts traded
on the bid there even 1971 traded on the
offer so you know that there was
somebody down there willing to absorb
all that mind all that selling with
their buying they're sitting there
bidding bidding bidding then it goes
offered and people are still buying it
you know they're still buying it even
it's offered at oh five okay a trades oh
four then it snaps back up so you know
you know look at this volume three
thousand where else do you see anything
remotely close to that you see one level
here in fifteen hundred but pretty much
at every level you're only looking at a
few hundred you know 500 600 700
contracts that's important that sticks
out like a sore thumb you know so they
go I call the sore thumb trade when you
see abnormally large volume at a low
that tells you there's support there or
you see abnormally large volume at a
high
that's support there it's important
information and what is commitment you
know what's being in a trade it's like
think of it like this you know it's like
the girl on the left right she doesn't
want to be committed you know she's just
throwing orders in the order book you
know she's out guys don't want to play
the field I still want to date other
people whereas the girl on the right you
know she's married and she's committed
you know putting the ring on it she's
happy to be committed she's in a trade
she's committed it like I say at some
point she's gonna get out but um you
know that's the difference and you have
to think about what happens in the
market in normal layman's terms you know
this girl on the left you know she
probably keep dating you know maybe you
may be dating some other people whereas
the girl on the right she's committed to
you and it's the same way you know when
you're in a trade you're committed when
you're not in a trade you can do
whatever you want now orders are filled
traded you know that's volume and it's
very revealing wise information wise to
you the trader you know think about it
if you knew where big buyers are a
certain level or were do you think
that's important you know if you knew
where big sellers were when price
rallied up to a certain level and big
buyers office and came out the woodwork
and so it's told the out of the
market that's going to be important
information to you so how can you tell
that's them that's the question is how
do you know where big buyers are
supporting the market or big sellers are
offering resistance well you look at the
order flow and more importantly you can
see it in the point of controls you know
and point of controls you know it's in
the price level in a bar
with the most volume now the primary
point of control is a point of control
it takes the point of control a step
further you know it takes
we are vanilla a point of control so to
speak your regular point of control that
you're looking at on a volume footprint
chart in colors it in to indicate
support or resistance by meeting certain
conditions in price action and order
flow analysis and you can see it it's
going to act as support or resistance
and you see how the markets you know
react to it you know you got up here you
got a resistance prominent point of
control to a supportive
primary port of control rally up to a
resistant point of control and you sell
off again you know oftentimes the
markets do react quite nicely like that
you know it's I know people say well
you're just putting up the charts where
it worked well you know what if you look
at enough chart it sometimes you think
at the same chart because you see it
over and over and over there are times
that it fails I'll admit you know
nothing is 100% in trading and you know
you have to keep that in mind but again
you know if you know where there's
resistance in the market you have offers
working up there to take advantage of it
you know you see how it tests it once
twice even here supported by and it
comes down here test that area before it
rallies back up and then comes off again
and when you start adding in a few other
pieces of order flow like divergence
with the prominent point of control you
know it gives you some nice traits like
up here at this high of the day you know
in here you got around reporter control
resistance followed by support okay yeah
but sometimes it happens like that but
again if you were to refine it a little
bit say well I'm gonna take it you know
if they got divergence then you know it
gives you an extra trade you know
trading is not about just having one
method that works period because you
know what there's so many different
market conditions you need several
different tools sometimes to attack the
different market conditions so you know
the million dollar question is how can
you know where hidden aggressive buyers
or hidden aggressive sellers are present
well you're gonna know with multiple
imbalances and they can occur it
anywhere any point on a chart but when
you take them in context they're going
to be more effective now what do I mean
by context you know this is where a lot
of traders go wrong is they think you
know they follow systems blindly in the
sense that you know they're taking buys
when they shouldn't be or taking sells
when they shouldn't be and it was a
perfect example you have a buying
multiple buying imbalance you have a
multiple selling imbalance right around
the highs which is going to be more
effective buying after a move up or
selling after a move up I've always
found the selling after a move up if you
have a valid reason is gonna be better
than buying after a long move up and you
can see here you got a multiple buying
imbalance bar but it's met with
resistance up here then even over here
it's met with resistance up here so you
know you got this top every time you hit
this top you met with resistance then
you got aggressive selling coming in and
the market goes lower you know those are
the types of trades that you want to be
taken not just because oh I got a
multiple buying imbalance or I got a
stacking balance I got to take it
I'll take it take a step back think
about it for a second you know can the
market go higher yes it can but if
you're up here at your high and you see
in signs of resistance then you know
it's not gonna be a very effective trade
instead you should be looking to take
the other trade a reason to be getting
short and multiple imbalances you know
the reason we added them into the
Oracles trader software is because you
know with order flow you're taught to
look for stacked imbalances and there's
nothing wrong with stacked imbalances
you know they're nice they're neat
they're pretty but oftentimes when
you're trading in the markets everything
is not nice and neat and pretty you know
it's it's like you know you go to high
school you take Auto class and all the
tools there are nice and shiny and
everything but you know you have your
car and it breaks down and go your tools
you know your your wrenches grimy and
greasy and you know maybe it's the nut
is or the bolt is stripped or something
and you know it's like that with the
market now everything is not nice and
neat you know so you know yeah it's nice
to get stacked imbalances to everything
stacking up neatly top of each other but
often times you don't get it you get
them spread out and it's just as
important because you know what if you
have a bar with three price three
imbalances and there's five price levels
in the bar so you look at a four range
chart you know that's important
information because over half the bar is
aggressive traders in a direction so
it's extremely important and it can also
help you get into trades that you
probably wouldn't have seen otherwise
you know for example you have three
points here point a point B Point C
point B is a nice neat stacked imbalance
at the end of a move well that's great
but where would you rather be buying
point A or point B one point a it's much
lower you get in a twenty seven ninety
two and a half catching the move all the
way up to 90 you know to here to ninety
six when you start coming off because up
here you got divergence you got a
bearish ratio you got a lot of things if
you took this trade the stack multiple
imbalance up here you would've been
stopped out okay you know that happens
especially you know this in the order
flow is very bearish you know as soon as
you get the stacking balance if it comes
back with a bearish ratio right after it
that's that's not a good sign that the
trade is gonna work out you got
immediately if it doesn't stop you out
but we come up here we make our turn
then you got aggressive sellers coming
in and the market sells off so you know
point a point B point C all multiple
imbalances but when you take it in
context point a point C are the two good
trades point B would be not a very
effective trade mean you can still take
it what you're gonna get stopped out but
if you take it in context you'd be like
well you know what I'm already long from
point A I don't need to get long from
point B and instead you see the market
turning so then you get out of your
initial trade and you get short because
not all of a sudden you got aggressive
sellers coming in here yeah another
another great example coming down in
here you got a low you got a problem
opponent control got some support and
you got multiple imbalances in this case
got multiple stacked imbalances and you
can see how the market reacts to it you
know it just comes up even here you got
multiple imbalances one two three four
and then the market keeps going higher
you know they said if you're just
looking at stacking balances sometimes
you get them sometimes you don't you
know here you got no stacking balancing
but you got multiple imbalances you got
a prominent opponent control as well
where does this market do it just it
rallies just kind of hangs around
lingers around it does come back down
here test this primary point of control
before taking off back up to an area
where you got a resistant prominent
point of control now the third thing
I'll talk about is why you don't need to
predict the market to be a successful
trader you know a lot of traders new
traders come into this come into the
trading world thinking well I'm just
going to get every single book on
trading I can find and read it and you
know take that information synthesize it
into a trading method and I will know
where the markets going to go well
instead of that instead of becoming a
traitor instead you're becoming a
fortune-teller unfortunately no pun
intended but you what I want to tell you
and I want to stress upon you is you
don't need to try and predict the future
you just trade based on the information
that's in front of you it's not about
trying to predict highs or lows it's
about the market telling you a high is
being made
Orolo is forming them okay and once you
understand that then you can start
trading you know the shackles come off
so to speak you know if you know they're
supported buying the first time the
market reaches a swing low you can
position yourself to get long right you
throw a bit in here okay to catch the
move back up alright you don't have to
sit here and say well I got a swing low
and we start drawing trend lines and
predict that I think the markets gonna
go up here to 93 oh that's all well and
good well where you gonna get in you
know you got your target up here you got
to get in at some point you know if you
had a way to understand where there's
trap traders right now based on what's
happening to the market it's gonna give
you some great trading opportunities and
you know the best way I've described
trap traders is someone that's long and
wrong or short in the hole and what I
mean by long and wrong is you know
you're you're late to a party basically
okay the market rallied up from this low
to this high where you got trap traders
on the buy side what's happening is the
market rallied up everyone's coming in
oh
I gotta get long I missed the move they
get long but maybe the reasons for this
rally are over now and then the market
starts selling off and these guys are
stuck up here they're trapped you know
they gotta get out of their positions
and what often happens is invariably the
market will continue in that direction
when they're wrong so you know trap
traders is something you see a lot of
people talking about and they talk about
it on bar charts but how do they know
it's really trap traders you don't if
it's on a bar chart because you're not
looking at at volume you're not taking
in volume to it that's what I talked
about white volume is important you know
market sweeps again trading what's
happening in the market right in front
of you you know it's like okay I see a
sweep happening okay in the next bar it
sells off from 15 down the double-o the
next couple minutes down to 73 90 you
know why is because someone came in and
swept the market and you only gonna know
that if you're looking at the order flow
and you're like I know a sweep is
happening if you're using the order flow
Strader software to indicate that to you
you know this is important information
that's there for traders to use and take
advantage of you know rather than sit
here and spending a year trying to read
every single book on trading that's out
there you know oftentimes written by you
know people that don't necessarily
trade you know um you know you gotta
make at some point you got a got a you
got to start trading you know that that
this leads me into the second point or
the fourth point is stop waiting for
confirmation and start trading you know
you got to be active and you know the
best way to describe it is it's kind of
like you know do you want to sit on the
bench or do you want to be playing in
the game you know you're gonna sit there
waiting for the coach to call you in or
like ready coach I'm in put me in put me
in you know you want to be that one that
that wants to play and oftentimes you
know problem that I see with a lot of
traders you know I do some mentoring
with traders and they show me their
charts and so well now I'm just waiting
for confirmation well what are you gonna
do in the meantime you know you can go
on vacation or something or what yeah
start trading you know don't don't sit
there on a sideline waiting waiting and
waiting
you know what trade what's happening
right now you know it's funny because
you know I've seen people show me charts
and they're like well I'm waiting for
this you know got the first part of this
formation forming so okay then what
you're gonna do you know it's like
they're well I'm sitting here waiting
for you know this this this but then
I'll be and I don't have the
confirmation and I can take the trade
well okay well first of all when's that
gonna happen today a week from now a
month from now I don't know I wait for
confirmation okay what you gonna do in
the meantime
well let's just keep looking at my chart
well it's not going to change that much
honestly and if yours they're waiting
for confirmation it may never come you
know like people like to oh I got triple
bottom here like on this chart then I'm
gonna buy on the breakout okay I need
confirmation that we got a triple bottom
before I could buy honestly after you
hit the second bottom you should already
be long right rather than oh gosh triple
bottom I gotta buy you know because
we're gonna make a fourth bottom you
know that's rare but it's it's almost
like people that go to the casino and
these cetana through that wheel and wait
for black to come up ten times in a row
then they start betting red thinking I
got my confirmation it's ten you know
how can it happen but it can it can
still go red for another ten spins or
black for another ten spins rather than
say okay you know what we're trading
black
that black you know that that's what
trading is like you know you got to
start trading rather than sit here
waiting waiting because if you're
waiting at the roulette wheel for ten
blacks in a roll a lot of spins going on
that you're not taking advantage of in
this chart here this is just two days
ago in the e minis it's very similar to
this chart actually it's quite eerie but
what you got here is you got your
primary point of control and you got
multiple imbalances so you know you got
support in this bind and you know you
got aggressive buyers coming in here so
what's happening is you're just going
sideways so this is your opportunity to
buy somewhere in here around this blue
line twenty eight fifteen and a half
rather than well I draw my trend line in
here we gotta break that trend line
before I can get long to confirm this
double bottom a triple bottom okay
well what if we don't come up here what
if we just trade all the way up here to
twenty one and then come back down you
just gave up a trade of getting long at
twenty eight fifteen twenty eight
eighteen and a half up to twenty eight
twenty one
you know that's two and a half points
was it three and a half points doing
that voice I can't think right now but
rather than getting long up here at
twenty eight twenty one and a half would
you rather be long eighteen and a half
or twenty-one and a half for the move up
to 25 and a half twenty we call twenty
four and a half right here you know you
just gave up an extra two and a half
points out of a five point realistically
a five point trade instead of getting
just two and a half points and we'll
think about your risk now okay where are
you gonna place your stop if you're
getting long here where you gonna place
your stop but your stops gonna go it
goes below that that triple bottom down
here right your stop goes here or your
long entries here your stop is here
right but if you're getting long in here
in here based on the order flow and you
still your stop is still the same point
and there's still the same spot right
down here so whether you're long at
eighteen and a half your stop is at
seventeen and a half
whether you're long at 21 and a half
your stop still at seventeen and a half
would have a stop with eighteen and a
half long at eighteen and a half of the
stop at seventeen and a half that's one
point or getting long at 21 and a half
with a stop at seventeen and a half you
know any day of the week you should take
the stop with
for ticks as opposed to 20 ticks you
know one point as opposed to five points
and what's your profit potential you
know your profit potential is five
points on the 18 and a halves versus you
know three points two and a half points
on the long at 21 and a half but your
risk is still the same you know that's
how you got to cut down your risk you
know traders like to overanalyze
situations rather than confront them you
know you gotta just start trading them
you know sit there wait for this I'm
looking I'm training up five minutes
charge I'm gonna look at a one-minute
chart and see if I got confirmation
there or they look at a 15-minute chart
see if it's going in the same direction
oh my god just trade you know oftentimes
that's the problem is traders tend to
look and wait you know they want
confirmation they don't want to jump in
to the trade even though the signals are
there because they want further
confirmation well at some point you got
a trade you know you just gotta pick it
up you know you gotta jump gotta get in
the game and start getting your foot on
the ball so to speak and you know people
that know me know me that I have certain
setups in order flow and you know they
use the order flows traders tools you
know and one of my bread-and-butter
trades is the divergence and ratio trade
and it's a great trade because it's
great for picking highs the days or lows
the days often and you get great moves
you know that anytime you could sell off
a high or buy off for low it's going to
give you a tremendous move yeah as you
can see here right this is the euro
currency but one of the the newer trades
the setups that we got is still involves
the or flows trader involves two other
tools the primary point of control which
I explained already you know which is
the point of control is considered
support or resistance in the order flow
and the divergence the order flows
divergence which is a new or equal high
with negative Delta or a new or equal
low with positive Delta but most
importantly confirming price action and
why is that important you know a lot of
the the trading tools out there don't
have the confirming price action they
just have the new or equal high with
negative Delta or new equal low with
positive Delta but you know what if I'm
looking for the market to move off the
high I want to see some confirming price
action I want the price action to be
also saying that the market is ready to
move off a high or move off
and that's what differentiates the order
foolish trader from the other software
authors we have the confirming price
action and you can see here I'm gonna
run through quickly a bunch of examples
primary point of control and divergence
up here at the height of the day sell
off from you know you'll be getting long
in the next part you gotta wait for the
bar to close don't just get all excited
as this bar is forming because often
times it can just change on you and keep
rallying but once the bar is closed
that's it it's printed you got your
divergent J prime opponent control and
you go from 47 you trade all the way
down to 42 five points right there and s
and peace another s peace again ratio
and divergence earlier it's a double top
you hit it again you got your divergence
primary opponent control even the next
bar multiple imbalances in here again
it's not stacking balances but it's one
two three four five and balances out of
a bar with nine price levels over half
the bar is selling imbalances that's
important information as well and you
can see how the market just sells off
the word soft who sells off to a new
loan on here we got a divergence buy and
next bar you've got the ratio and the
stack multiple imbalances rather but
again you know it's a move from 2750
down 2745 another five points in the
espys I'm not talking about five to
expound five points you know I see some
of these traders videos they talk about
yeah I got three ticks out of this move
on these three ticks wasting your time
you know you gotta be thinking in points
that's when you gonna make money is
trading in points not in ticks all the
time and you can but you know you kind
of do a lot of trades but is it bonds
you know ratio uh prominent the point of
control and divergence right up here
getting short around the twenty three it
sells off to where area we got supported
buying prominent point of control you
know Psalm 23 down fourteen mini Dow
eight range right on the swing low or
the low of the day rather
divergence Rama Porter control puts in a
nice rally here you go another one euro
currency you sell off from a permanent
point of control resistance here new
lows new lows
primary point of control divergence and
your rally back up you know where would
you be your initial target would be this
previous point of control prominent
point of control up here and you can see
once you hit that area you start sort of
spinning around
slightly above it we start spinning
around that area ones same thing it's
just like that emini chart that I showed
you earlier triple bottom here
divergence divergence divergence from
opponent control permanent border
control a ratio here but if you know you
got support you could be buying in here
no one bins in here instead of drawing
this trend line here and saying well
when we break 33 I'm gonna get long you
can be getting long down here at 27 you
know it's gonna give you an extra five
or six ticks out of that trade because
you know you got support of mine
happening you know back to the e minis
again here you got you know a lot of
stuff going on prominent point of
control you got divergence you got trap
traders you got a ratio everything going
on the only thing you don't have here is
multiple imbalances or a stacked
imbalance even but you know you got
everything telling you this is sometimes
I say the market just grabs you by the
neck and says hey buy me and buy me here
that's what's happening here and again
you know sometimes these charts look a
lot of like is because you know they
repeat themselves they're not exactly
alike but you know what the same sort of
setups appeared daily that's why I said
oh my gosh I wish I had a tool that
would allow me to look at five markets
six markets at a time so that when these
things happen I can take advantage of it
because if I'm in a trade
sometimes that's got all my attention
and I'm not looking at these other
markets and ultimately I ended up
missing you're missing the the setups so
hopefully by now you can see how
powerful order flow analysis has become
and you know if you found this helpful
you're gonna really like my order flow
trader 2.0 software package it's
literally like having me sitting next to
you while you're trading pointing out
the market nuances you know not all of
us were born in the matrix not all of us
have a chip in our head that we can do
to calculate everything that's going on
at once you know sometimes we need tools
to help us with that and that's why I
created the order flows trader software
you know it runs on ninjatrader seven or
NinjaTrader eight and what it is it's
the volume footprint chart with the
seven pre-programmed tools that I
discuss in this presentation and more
importantly what you're also going to
get is my chart template and that's
important is because
don't want to waste your time trying to
configure your chart to look just like
mine you know what you do what you want
is your chart to look like mine as
quickly as possible
you know don't dick around trying to get
everything set up then you change some
setting and then you're like oh my gosh
what did I just do and you screwed
something up and you guys start over
again it's a waste of time stop wasting
your time
normally I sell this for $8.99 on my
website you can go there and buy it on
my website but you know one thing I
learned about vendors software vendors
in the trading space is like I said
there's there's two types you know
there's the type that just sort of build
it and then that's it they're done I've
done what I want to do I set out to
build my volume footprint chart and
that's it and then there's the others
that once they build it they say ok they
step back how can I improve it you know
and that's where we are with the order
foolish trader software we always like
to add improvements when when we can I
mean it's not like monumental shifts but
you know they come out when I say hey
you know what I've added another tool to
my training let's put it in the software
and you know that's the difference is
the orthos trader was designed by a
trader for traders you know that's why
we release the new tools because it's
based on how people are trading with
order flow and my goal was to take the
analysis that I do in my head or on a
calculator I used to do a lot of the
stuff you know with the ratios and all
that on in my head or on a calculator I
could do the rough math in my head but
sometimes I need to do a calculator if
it doesn't make sense and programming it
into the software to highlight the areas
where potential buying or selling
opportunities up here no you know that's
all well and good you know it's nice to
have software that can do this but you
gotta know how to use it all right
that's important also you know it's it's
like having you know a what is that's a
Photoshop right Photoshop Adobe
Photoshop is a month it's a terrific
program but if the learning curve on it
is so hard and order flow training is
sometimes the same way that's why I like
to give you a lot of extra further
education on how to trade with order
flow and so I'm gonna give you they give
you access to my order flows training
course normally I sell this for 297 on
my website you don't get free access to
that so you can have that as a resource
you know go back and you know say you
want to know more about the absorption
you go there watch the lesson on
absorption so you want to know more
about trap traders you go watch the
lesson on trap traders and I realized
though but some people you know they're
they're really voracious in their
appetite for learning order flow so I
got a special treat is when you pick up
the software now will give you access to
my inner circle video series this is
different than the actual inner circle
the inner circle includes extra
indicators but this is for people that
want to take their order flow to another
level in order for training to another
level maybe they want to learn some
extra tips or tricks or forms of
analysis and you can see that in they're
normally sell this for 497 and it's a
great resource for people and this is
just the videos again it's not the
additional indicators but when you start
adding this up you know it's $8.99 for
the software 297 for the training
another 497 for the inner circle video
series that's ready well it's almost
1,700 dollars at 1693 okay but you know
in response to invest your inspiration
keep inviting me back I want to make it
sweeter for you okay I want to give you
a special bonus this is the access to
the trader kickstart training it's
advanced trader training this deals with
the mindset of a trader
you know why traders succeed why traders
fail how to help you build a trading
plan you know how to set a daily routine
and you know how to relieve the stress
and basically become a better trader on
the mental side because you know dealing
on the mental side of training it's very
taxing it's it's not something that's
normally talked about but you know
sometimes people like to think that you
know well trading is scalable well I
think if I'm successful trading one Lots
I can move up to ten Lots overnight and
then they end up losing it's not you
know you have to be have the right
mindset you have to understand yourself
before you can do it you know that's
that's important and normally I sell
that for about $300 to 97 so you start
adding this together it's just about
$2,000 its 1990 but you're not gonna pay
that okay I don't want you to pay that I
mean there's some people out there that
bought each and everything separately
and I'm like come on don't do that you
know you just let me know if you want to
bundle everything up I can give you a
special deal you know and today you can
get it for just $7.99
I'm gonna be raising this price later
after this webinar promotion so you're
not gonna be able to get it at this
price anymore and what you do is you go
to order flows comm slash oft to the
HTML there's no more monthly payments
you know there's software out there it's
got an extra zero after this price for
this for less than what I have to offer
you in terms of analysis or education
and it boggles my mind people pay it I
get a lot of people say hey you know
what I've spent $10,000 on software over
the last three years on order flow and
then I bought your software for you know
1/10 the price and it all know it makes
sense you know it's all come together
for me they're like I wish I found you
before I pissed away all this other
money I'm like oh I'm sorry to hear that
you pissed away all that money but I'm
glad you found me
and you know I got a new thing that I
just started its the weekly live group
training session it's online it's not
one-on-one it's a group thing it's in my
training room software hosts I want to
go back to it and what it is is each
week Monday night's 7:00 p.m. Central
time get on a call with anybody that
wants to come in to the room and you
know ask questions ask help questions as
support questions anything about trading
zip up a chart you know show me this you
know and I'll explain you know anything
interesting I saw recently in the order
flow and explain it to you so it's it's
a resource for users of my software and
it's only available for users of the
order flows trader software these videos
will not be posted on YouTube it's going
to be behind a password-protected place
for members for users of the order flows
trader software and again it's a place
where say you want to ask me something
in you want to send me an email
honestly I get about 700 emails a day of
which about 25 are actually applicable
to me and sometimes I miss them you know
and I know that's an issue with a lot of
people I admit it and I apologize for
that but that's why I'm doing this live
weekly group training session is so you
can ask your questions there you can say
hey Mike what does this setting mean you
know do I need to look at it you
can ask that there you know that's where
I'll be every week so you know say you
can't reach me for a few days
oh it's Mike are you still alive what's
going on I'm there you know you can come
into that room and ask your questions
there so you know for those of you that
in the past have said well you know I
sent you an email you never replied well
this is your chance to interact with me
live it basically it's a set time each
week so you know I'm going to be there
and you can take advantage of it and you
know I put the value that this is $1,000
because even if you just go there once
or twice then you get the time with me
because why is it why do I value it so
much is because it's you know I do
mentoring occasionally for people and
it's only for select people now it's
because you know I want to make sure
people are serious about their trading
you know not just like well can order
for work for me here's some money teach
me what you know and if it doesn't work
no I want to make sure you know you want
to understand it and normally I would
charge two and half thousand for five
hours so that's five hundred dollars an
hour for mentoring so even if you just
come here twice in in the lifetime that
you hate you know that you're you're
trading you know you're ready getting a
thousand dollars of value but you could
come in here any time say you buy the
software today and you going on vacation
for a month you can come in after you
get back and you know say you've been
using the software for six months you
could still get in you know previous
users are also going to have access to
this and you know say you're using the
software from going on for you know
three months you never have any
questions also you got a question you
come in here you can have access to this
for you know for life you know this is
the resource that you come in and use it
to contact me on a regular basis you
know not everybody likes to you know
talk about trading you know some people
are secretive some people will come in
here and just sit back and watch and
that's fine you know it's not something
where you have to come in specifically
to ask a question you could come in here
and you know just listen to the exchange
of ideas you know it's it's not a
trading room I don't like having a
trading room because people want to say
well just tell me where to buy and sell
no that's not what this is about this is
about learning is about furthering your
education in order
hello and I said you know it's it's you
get lifetime access to that so this it's
a great tool it's a great resource for
you so again you know get started for
just a one-time payment of $7.99 you
know you again you don't have to not
gonna come back and say next year you
gotta pay another $7.99 or you want to
upgrade your software you gotta pay
another fee for that no you know the
only time you got to pay extras they you
want another license of the orthos
trader software which we can provide at
a discounted price so you start adding
that together you know that you're
saving a lot of money you know you're
saving instead of paying twenty nine
ninety you're only paying seven
ninety-nine it's a huge savings you know
other people have had great success by
learning order flow for me you know
Sheila writes you know your order flow
straighter software is remarkably
helpful I can clearly see now what's
happening in the market like for example
who's in control of the market on a very
specific time and who's getting weaker
as well you know it's information like
that you know that that's available to
you as a trader that you should use in
your trading and again it's not overly
expensive but again you ask yourself
where are you now where do you want to
be in the future in your trading you
know do you want to try and figure it
out on your own or do you want to have
somebody there that's been using order
flow that's been developing the software
been creating the tools that are helping
traders being able to have access to
them and talk to them you know what's
that worth to you you know that that's a
great resource so what you do is you go
to order flows calm the slash off to
Daiichi Mela takes you to this page and
you just scroll down to the bottom of
the page takes it here by now I want
this it takes you to PayPal PayPal
process your payment I don't get your
payment information I don't want your
payment information
I don't want your credit card details
people think that all you know you've
got my credit card details know you know
it's passed process through PayPal if
you've ever bought anything online you
should be familiar with PayPal and you
think about it why you should join order
flows today's because hopefully by now
you see the power of order flow analysis
and how it can change your trading you
want to understand what's happening in
the markets you're excited to find low
risk training opportunities you want a
life of freedom and fulfillment you know
and that's what trading is about it's
gonna give you that freedom and
fulfillment I mean you know it took me
to my 40s to realize the the freedom
that I could have you know in fulfilment
by spending time with my family you know
I worked hard all my life and I gained
the knowledge in trading and I said hey
you know what if I could like share that
with other people that would be great
you know it's funny because people don't
understand they think well Mike if
you're such a great trader why don't you
just trade well I do trade but then they
say well why why while they're teaching
people you know it must be frustrating
it honestly I get a lot of fulfillment
out of helping other people you know
when I get these emails from people
saying you know you're trading courses
helped me understand order flow Thanks
you know or people say you know it
really made a difference in my training
that's worth it you know that that one
email like that you know really
brightens up my day and you know really
gives me happiness and you know trading
like I said is a journey okay that's why
I talk about the trading kickstart
course where you know it's not something
that happens overnight
you know it takes time and you have to
find your footing right there's a
there's a saying Chinese you know the
probably won't confuse saying you know
the best time to plant a tree was 20
years ago well what's the next best time
is today and you have to make that you
know you gotta plant a tree you know you
could sir you could spend the next year
trying to figure it out on your own or
you could spend the next month two
months you know get the courses get the
software and get up to speed as quickly
as possible you know when I talk about
having a life of freedom you know when
when I was in Singapore trading you know
I I would see these guys I was amazed
you know because I never realized how
much freedom you could have you know in
life if you're a successful trader and
what do I mean perfect example is it
would be Friday afternoon floors closed
and be five o'clock and these guys would
be like hey let's get it let's go to
Thailand this weekend and we just what's
you talking about man because you
got your passport yeah cuz you know
foreigner and when you're foreign or
overseas always carries your passport
it's okay he's good cab we go to the
airport and we just buy a ticket there
and we just go to Thailand for the
weekend that's the freedom you know when
I was still single I was able to do that
now that I'm married I can't do that but
um yeah
you know that's that's what
you want to do you know say you want to
go on a vacation with your family if
you're trading and you're successful at
it you know what you're doing you can
take that time off because you know what
the markets gonna be there tomorrow it's
going to be there next week it's going
to be under a month from now mark has
been around for you know 150 years
before you were born it's why gonna be
there for next 250 years at least in
some form so you know there's you have
that freedom to take the time off when
you want spend it with your family and
do that so you know most importantly I
can't stress this enough stop wasting
your money flushing it down the toilet
you know thinking that you're trying to
buy some shiny new indicator that's
going to tell you where to buy here and
sell there you know these Holy Grail
things they don't exist you know
sometimes people would like to tell you
they do they really don't especially not
for like $100 you can't buy some
indicator that's going to work honestly
I've been working with some people to
develop some order flow algos and you
know they would work nicely but honestly
it's not good available to general
public like that it's it's very
expensive work and you know does that
mean it's going to constantly keep
working no you know but once you
understand how to unreadiness thats
worth more than having some holy grail
indicator because at some point they may
work it might show you may stop working
you know you look at some of these these
great hedge funds and what worked for
them 20 years ago probably doesn't work
for them now you know that's why some of
these these methods of trading aren't
very effective anymore is because you
know these algos have been created to
pick off some inefficiencies and you
know that's that's something you got to
understand and not a lot of people
really understand that so thanks for
watching this video you know this was a
this was a long presentation and again I
promised you if you were interested in
my book on trading order flow go to
order flow comm slash book at HTML take
you to a page enter your email address
confirm it and you'll be taken to a page
where you can download the book you know
it's it's it's a great book it said if
you're interested in the markets and
order flow in particular take advantage
of it there's no reason not to so you
know get started now I mean what are you
waiting for you know
we'll watch this video this presentation
the replay or whatever and do nothing
then a year from now you'll see come
back to it say you know what I should
have just bought your software today and
instead of wasting a year of my life you
know who knows you know
were you gonna be in a year you know
maybe you got different priorities you
know and you're like well you know I
wish gosh I wish I knew how to trade
because I really hate my new boss you
know I've worked in places where I hated
my boss so much you know and it's like I
can't wait to get out of here oh he
moves or I move or something like that
and you know when you're successful at
trading it gives you that freedom to
make the the movements in life that you
want to make give you the freedom to do
the things in life that you want to make
so again you know go to order closed
comm slash off to dot html' and I hope
to see you guys inside on the inside and
you know have an interaction with you on
a regular basis so thanks everyone have
a great day bye bye